welcome to this pin 50-meter
game-playing be wrong be a bear off okay
or keep gotta what is this the center
gambit Oh what is this this is a weird
move autumn hmm this is a ruse off
gambit I think there is a opening like
that Knight f6 yeah the probably will
transpose now 93 is what they do yeah I
think black now can check on you for but
is rather risky there is this check on
before One Nights is 6mm what should I
do here check for c3 details be takes d5
what just nights is six with the
transposition but I think the case is
actually quite good see three year and
Jake's takes d5 ed5 bishop t6 this is
definitely okay for black and I am not
sure what else he can do hmm I wonder if
I'm i think i actually confused this
right with the default takes on to d4
takes Knight f3 but anyway this is
definitely not a bad position for black
this pawn structure with the pawn on d5
and the poem see three years definitely
I'm totally ok 44 black I'm just going
to develop simple simple fashion this
position is um in comparison far more
favorable for black then let's say
compared to d4 c3 pawn structure yeah d5
the pawn on d5 gives me the square z 5
and c5 and makes his bishop on c4 look
rather stupid so I'm definitely in in
okay shape him um snotty five a threat
okay I don't want to give up my bishop
pair just yet
yeah Knight b6 might also be a move
looking at the d5 pawn but I have some
more useful moves like rook e8 for
example and also there is 95 which will
exchange a number of pieces hmm Jerry
not stop thinking about this for too
long look yet is definitely an okay move
hmm I did not think about this one not
at all I don't quite understand that if
I take it with the rook rook takes root
cheeks and then g5 am I not winning some
material then I think I do hmm g5 is not
so good in comparison i think but let's
do that I think it just works and now g5
which is basically a double attack on
the rook and the bishop if you place
night x g5 I will take the rook not just
a night
95 his denies pinned poor okay not a
good not a good way to start calculation
in this game I think not takes d5 okay
but this means that i really don't see a
good move him he probably has to move
the rock up yeah he has to move the rock
is back to you one or something
when t4 maybe she takes h4 Luke takes h4
this might be might be on yeah but I can
take e for right this is this a stuck to
pieces g takes gh4 and an additional
piece up an additional piece up is
probably kind of weird way to to to
describe it I'm a piece up now so not g5
probably check yeah this looks like not
just a piece but also pretty nice attack
yeah so green age seven that's not even
a real threat but no reason to allow
anything okay if I go Bishop h21
threatening Queen g1 check made I don't
quite see how he answers that one
now that's made that's really made he
can only play some kind of disparate
resides yeah I was again a quick game
kind of a pseudo blitz game it's in the
rare in the rapid jam control yeah I'm
actually am a bit curious about the
opening I mean okay it's clear that this
is this is a move but it is also kind of
risky I think it is something like that
slan Bishop g5 and long and white has a
ton ton of development the the main
continuation has just knight c6
transposing into the two nights defense
but I was thinking that this is Jaisal
probably it is but this is not the
situation that I was thinking of I was
thinking of this here I think there is
this check check if i'm not wrong no
awesome there is a line maybe i'm
confusing things and chess is actually
what I'm what I'm referring to 195 well
okay take stakes actually here maybe
what should take I don't know this is
variant idea check try to exploit what I
did I'm not a porn up here but it's not
entirely clear because of my shaky King
position may be here i'm ok i'm pretty
pretty sure about that ok the engine
wants to get a check here ya can't make
some sense so this is not really great
so green here and then check I'm at
least not very well kawaii needed yeah
that might be better I think in the game
it's it's pretty pretty quickly we come
to a situation where I'm really
comfortable here I've got good complete
development yeah I could also already
take and play 95 but I did not want to
play so such a simple way he ate yeah a
94 is just not working played in six
seconds yeah those kind of very
committal moves you should should
consider more carefully maybe yeah this
is just just winning from like I guess
and that was really singing for mom that
this is a more bunch of course I can
just take the Queen yeah I think this is
what he has to do and trying to try to
play this position covering here
preparing this preparing loopy aid yeah
this is a position where I have two
minor pieces against rook and pawn but
the rookie is not really great down on
each form or you can also argue that the
two pieces are for the rook on a one
whatever but it seems like black is some
quite substantially better simply
because also that I have a tons of good
squares like c5 for both pieces efore
possibly for the night later rupee aid
yeah i mean the comp is already on minus
1 point 7 which seems kind of kind of
fair you probably should try to exchange
my my opening here with the capture on
before jesus this is kind of unclear it
is opposite colored bytch bishops and
white might have some chances form for
initiative based on my somewhat shaky
King position maybe maybe that was some
was best okay well thanks for watching